malgré l'annoncé du gel global des
fonctionnements et la diminution des
dotations saint cyr l'école se doit
comme toutes les communes françaises de
présenter un budget à l'équilibré des
décisions économique impacte la vie des
habitants
c'est pourquoi le maire a décidé de
parler finances locales et de les
convier à une réunion jeudi dernier
je suis venu plutôt comprendre ce que le
maire a présenté comme le dj skee le
contenu à partir du contenu bon jeu
pourrait émettre des vedettes l'éthique
j'aimerais bien aussi que les questions
de logement soient plus abordables entre
2012 et 2014 la commune de saint cyr a
perdu 200 3000 euros de subventions
selon le ministère de l'économie et des
finances la situation oblige les élus à
prendre des décisions qui ne font pas
forcément l'unanimité notamment ceux qui
concernent la hausse des impôts on va
expliquer aux gens ce dans quel état
sont les finances de la commune
ça sera pas des choix unique il ya
forcément des choix dans la gestion il
va y avoir des choix dans
l'investissement c'est obligatoire la
réunion de ce soir sur le site pour
exposer aux habitants que nous sommes
obligés de faire des choix par rapport à
nos engagements
l'augmentation des impôts pourrait
compenser ces baisses de dotations même
si rien n'a encore été votée pour la
seule année 2015 la commune de saint cyr
l'école a vu diminuer son budget de plus
de cinq cent cinquante mille euros